[Música]
boa tarde bom primeira coisa que eu
tenho pra dizer pra vocês é que têm um
completo desconhecido dentro de mim é
isso mesmo estou na minha primeira
gravidez e está sendo muito louco
imaginar o que é que vai sair de mim
daqui a uns meses né quem vai sair daqui
de dentro
será que vai ser um médico um artista um
transexual
uma pessoa com deficiência a gente nunca
sabe eu estou me preparando para receber
esse desconhecido com os braços abertos
na minha vida e isso tem me feito pensar
muito no meu nascimento é afinal de
contas por que que eu nasci o que eu tô
aqui nesse mundo a resposta disso eu
tenho eu gostei pra chegar nela vocês
vão entender como então vamos voltar lá
para o início essa daqui é a marinha eu
me chamo carinhosamente de marinha
uma menina que pelo olhar dá pra gente
ver eu era muito curiosa e eu me
encantava contudo tudo e todos desde o
tronco das árvores a pele dos idosos os
cabelos diferentes das pessoas e eu
conversava puxava assunto com todo mundo
porteiro cara da banca de revista e eu
botava meus pais vergonha porque desde
pequeno já era uma repórter mirim e eu
perguntava meu pai para focar no sinal
perguntava por que você é pobre
aí eu andava mais um pouco na cidade de
repente eu deparava com alguém você
trabalha no domingo
nossa você bebe você não tem mulher não
é muito cara de paulo desde pequena e aí
eu achava o mundo incrível tudo me
encantava mas logo cedo eu descobri
também que o mundo era muito cruel e que
me mostrou isso foi o trabalho do meu
pai meu pai tem um dos trabalhos que eu
considero um dos mais tristes elmôr de
orgulho mas é um dos trabalhos mais
tristes do mundo
ele é médico de um hospital público
pediatra especialista em queimaduras
infantil
então desde muito cedo eu convivi
diariamente com histórias muito tristes
guedes verdadeiras criança que era a
única sobrevivente do incêndio que matou
a família inteira criança que foi jogada
para fora do carro durante um acidente e
se queimou no asfalto criança que o
próprio pai botou fogo nela
então desde cedo aprendi também que o
mundo era muito cruel e com a nossa
maravilhosa sociedade machista
brasileira eu aprendi que o lugar da
mulher não era onde ela queria esse é o
lugar do homem lugar da mulher a mim é
uma garotinha cabia fala baixo e fechar
as pernas ficar quietas e discreta doce
carinhosa
logo eu quero um capeta eu era menina
que fazia de tudo eu tive uma infância
que a maioria dos meus amigos não
tiveram infelizmente andava de bicicleta
invadir casa abandonada subir em árvore
eu era muito eclética e eu brincava de
boneca com as meninas mas também jogava
futebol com os meninos
uma das maiores lembranças alegres que
eu tenho da minha infância era
exatamente de jogar futebol na quadra do
meu prédio custasse o que custasse
porque tinha um preço eu tinha que
encarar o bullying os olhares dos
vizinhos na janela que olhavam torto
eu me lembro de um amiguinho que chegou
pra mim uma vez disse
o meu pai falou que você é mulher márcia
eu era só uma criança
e aí eu vi também que o mundo é muito
injusto né
aí vai a pré adolescência na pré
adolescência eu aprendi o que é o
assédio aprendi a ter medo de andar nas
ruas não tinha tanta liberdade assim
mais e aprende também rapidamente até
vergonha do meu próprio corpo
andar pelas ruas e ser assediada recebeu
o que a gente chama de cantada diferia
muito me sentia muito invadida e com o
tempo passei realmente a esconder o meu
corpo durante um bom tempo da minha vida
eu andava assim com uma blusa de frio
amarrada na cintura por dia ao sol
rachando pra esconder o meu corpo e
tentar evitar um pouco do assédio que me
incomodava tanto mas o pior mesmo foi o
dia que eu senti uma dorzinha assim no
meu peito
aí eu peguei para ver o que querem
descobrir um carocinho falei cada isso
aqui vai virar um seio ferrou
aí eu me tranquei no banheiro chorar ano
treme muito meus peitos para que ele não
cresceu em por eisenhower aqui por favor
que eles não crescesse e que eu também
não ficará situada
eu não queria ser mais mulher do que eu
já era numa sociedade tão injusta e acho
que não deu certo né bebê é o meu pedido
não foi atendido e aí veio a
adolescência com adolescência veio
primeiro namorado a
o primeiro amor ele me ensinou tanto ele
me ensinou o que é que era a agressão
ele me ensinou que era boletim de
ocorrência coisa que muitas de nós
mulheres brasileiras conhecemos afinal a
cada hora 177 mulheres são espancadas no
nosso país
e aí diante disso tudo sabe que eu fiz
eu podia ter calado eu podia ter me
tornado a menina introspectiva
mas eu escolhi me revoltar completamente
tudo o que diziam ah isso aí é coisa de
menina não viu isso aí não é coisa de
mulher fazer pegar mal aí que eu fazia
bisbo para esse cara aí tá eu pegava
essa raiva e movia sabe então quer dizer
que mulher não joga futebol
eu passei a jogar no meio dos meninos
até aprender e quando eu fiquei boa
naquilo é ajudei a ajudei a fundar a
primeira escolinha de futebol feminino
do meu colégio e joguei a vida inteira é
por exemplo quando andava nas ruas
também de uma coisa que eu fazia muito
assim os caras que me encantavam se
responde a cada um deles
ensinaram que eu devia ficar calada é se
alguém te canta rússia finge que não viu
segue reto e tal eu respondi a cada um
eu gritava falava gostosa da boca
nossa dele se eu te pego km com esta
falando comigo então era se uma feminazi
praticamente andando pelas ruas sem
saber que era o feminismo matava minha
mãe de vergonha mas era isso eu tinha
escolhido ser a mulher que eu queria ser
não a mulher que queria que eu fosse
essas histórias eu conto no meu livro
infantil que é o primeiro do brasil até
que enfim meu país do futebol
uma literatura infantil com uma menina
como protagonista no universo do futebol
bom
aí com essa história né eu fui ficando
cada vez mais forte e sensível também
infelizmente a minha sensibilidade eu
joguei para debaixo do tapete lá do meu
inconsciente em algum lugar lá e me
tornei uma mulher muito guerreira forte
independente e fui pra vida e aí adulta
já na minha carreira eu deslanchei bom
foguete eu construir eu trabalhei nos
maiores canais de tv do país
e foi exatamente no meio mais machista
do mundo que é o futebol que eu me
destaquei
então eu estou nem repórter nacional eu
cobri grandes eventos como a olimpíada
copa do mundo mundial de clubes
libertadores enfim um monte de coisa e
aí eu fui crescendo crescendo fui parar
no estúdio me tornei apresentador de
televisão eu estava ao vivo todos os
dias na casa das pessoas num programa
que era líder de audiência
resumindo eu estava no auge de gente e
ronaldinho gaúcho queria namorar comigo
né
seus melhores dias né pois é mas
acontece que eu não estava feliz
eu estava me tornando uma pessoa
gananciosa sem tempo me gabar de não ter
tempo e se eu continuasse daquele
caminho escalar uma montanha atrás da
rota crescendo crescendo e me tornar uma
pessoa viciada em poder infame dinheiro
a gente vê várias por aí
isso não tinha absolutamente nada a ver
com o que eu vim fazer esse mundo e foi
aí que eu fiz uma das coisas mais
difíceis da minha vida eu parei
silêncio com a moda né
e olha que foram três segundos aqui só
com respirei foi exatamente isso que eu
fiz eu aprendi a ficar em silêncio para
entrar padre ir pra dentro de mim e
reconectar com a minha verdadeira
essência
foram anos de terapia psicanálise
meditação e yoga viagem sozinha eu
construir essa reconexão comigo e aí eu
voltei lá pra trás né
aquela menininha para a marinha que ela
é guerreira que veio para o mundo
como eu disse para vocês para
sensibilizar e para encorajar as pessoas
esse é meu propósito no mundo
e aí eu decidi transformar tudo que eu
tinha construído em alguma coisa que
fizesse sentido pra mim mas que também
fosse bom para o mundo
aí eu pedi demissão do emprego estável
de um lugar que muita gente queria tá
foi um escândalo verdadeiro para
empreender lançar o meu canal no youtube
onde o conto toda semana histórias para
melhorar o mundo
eu dou visibilidade para quem geralmente
não têm visibilidade e enquanto cresce
no nosso país um discurso de ódio propõe
um diálogo humanista e propõe que a
gente discute as pessoas que a gente
discutir os diferentes que a gente
aprenda a se colocar no lugar do outro e
agradeço todos os dias os meus
seguidores porque é preciso sair da zona
de conforto questionar os próprios
preconceitos para ser meu seguidor para
ouvir um transexual falando houve um
morador de rua
os idosos são ricos em sabedoria ea
gente ignora eles na rua então eu decidi
conta essas histórias e claro que eu
escolhi o caminho mais difícil eu não
tenho um milhão de seguidores
até porque eu vou completamente contra
as métricas de sucesso da internet é que
são vídeos curtos rápido self tal não eu
levo youtube a sério eu considero que eu
faço cinema em uma equipe comigo trilhas
próprias meus vídeos são longos as
conversas a gente precisa ouvir né não é
aquela coisa curta e rápida então é o
caminho mais difícil e é isso que eu
escolhi mas eu tenho certeza que eu
estou no lugar certo o davi e eu tenho
certeza que estou no lugar certo porque
eu sei
as universidades públicas e particulares
têm usado os meus vídeos para ajudar na
educação de crianças adolescentes e até
adultos e eu recebo mensagens
inspiradoras de pessoas de todo tipo me
dizendo carreira eu desistir de mudar de
cidade por causa dos seus vídeos aprendi
a olhar minha cidade com outros olhos
maíra eu nunca tinha parado para me
colocar no lugar de um gay eu era tão
preconceituoso agora estou tentando
mudar e tal e o mais legal disso tudo é
que as minhas histórias ela não acaba
são só o começo de outras histórias de
outros projetos
eu realmente inspira encoraja as pessoas
e aí é muito legal ver que prédios
antigos que têm potencial turístico na
minha cidade estão sendo revitalizadas
monte de coisa que acontece a
diversidade vencer promovida em fim mas
esse é o meu jeito né
essa é quem eu sou que olhe para as
árvores desde pequenininha com todo
carinho do mundo e é a minha história
meu propósito de vida que eu quero aqui
hoje é que vocês pensem em quem vocês
acham que vocês vieram fazer aqui eu
quero inspirar as pessoas a estimularem
né serem elas mesmas a respeitarem claro
as outras pessoas como elas são
e aí como mãe tudo o que eu quero eu me
preparando muito pra isso junto com o
pai do meu filho pra gente dá toda a
estrutura pra que esse homem seja um
homem sensível porque o machismo é muito
cruel com os homens também não podem
chorar
e pra que a gente dê estrutura para ele
ser o que quiser ser nesse mundo ele
cumpriu o que ele veio fazer aqui é tudo
que eu quero como mãe e aí eu pergunto
pra você
quem é você obrigado
[Aplausos]